we chose this clip because it really
shows the complexity of the structure of
this film
it begins with um maggie's olympic
trials in the summer of 2016
which in reality is about a year after
usag
knew about what nassar was doing to some
of its elite athletes
we really weren't going to go public or
say anything because we were told that
there's an fbi investigation and we
could possibly jeopardize it
and also you know we didn't want to
upset
you know steve penny and marta carolee
they knew that maggie reported larry
nassar
we had to do exactly what they wanted us
to do
you know this is this is public footage
it's um it's
uh you know olympic footage that was
aired on nbc
and yet um from the nichols family point
of view they're experiencing
this thing completely differently than
how the public is experiencing it they
have the sort of internal
drama that's going on between them and
usag regarding maggie's complaint about
nassar
and so you're i think as the public sort
of experiencing this
footage in a completely different way
than you would have normally had you
watch this on television
and also from the nichols family
perspective you know maggie was this
elite athlete she was second in the
world
behind simone vials and for many of
these competitions
in the year leading up to trials they
were treated like
you know the elite parents and they were
followed around by camera crews
and treated royally and they were
starting to notice things at olympic
trials that were starting to look a
little bit different
[Applause]
just the double fall great landings yeah
and because we
decided to put maggie and the nickels in
their own
kind of bubble their own timeline
i remember when we first cut the scene
we it was like 15 minutes long we had
tons of
other interviews sort of backing up the
nickels like yeah there was some foul
play
but you know in in dissecting the film
and making it
into these two timelines that would
eventually merge
the constraint on baggies uh pods or
maggie's timeline was that you could
only
as a viewer we could only know what the
nickels knew at the time
you know we had camera crews following
us you know even at the americas cup
a couple weeks prior we had a camera
crew following us throughout the whole
arena
[Music]
but we showed up at olympic trials and
our seats aren't marked
we don't have mics there's no camera
crew
following us and so
something was definitely off
yeah i mean i think this scene is a good
example archival plays such a key role
in the film
too um and you know we hope in a lot of
these scenes where you're looking at
olympic footage or olympic trial footage
in this case
you know some of that footage may be
familiar to people but um
you know see the pomp and circumstance
and all the marketing
that goes around it um we hope now you
see it in a sort of different light as
you realize what a key
part all that marketing played in this
abuse story
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
president and ceo
of usa gymnastics steve penny
yeah the other thing i just realized in
watching this is that
you know earlier in the film we've sort
of hopefully
trained the audience a little bit to to
like
look a little bit under the surface of
what's happening in all this glitz and
glory this at least hopefully gives the
audience
you know the license to like actually
realize that maybe there's other things
going on under the surface
well yeah you see steve penny there who
is the master of ceremonies at the
trials
uh kind of like a barnum bailey sort of
salesman type figure
calling out these athletes with you know
kind of clever
um preludes to their to their names um
but we know by now
that um he's the guy that's kind of
keeping the
the clamp down on any information
getting out about maggie's complaint
regarding nassar so i think you're
you're right down you're looking at this
in a completely different way than you
would be a viewer
ally raisman
hey uh jeff why don't you talk about the
music in this
scene is also really important because
um i think it helps
change the tone we kind of suck the
sound out of the the diegetic
scene and and really a lot of this is
done with the score
yeah i love this moment we're actually
coming into here
[Music]
[Applause]
i mean i've trained my whole life to
make that olympic team and then not
making it
even as an alternate i think i was
mentally and physically just
ready to move on there's two places in
the in the scene where we sort of pull
back from all the natural sound and the
archival and the score plays this very
haunting
texture over which a few solo
instruments played meg was crushed
she had you know many things taken away
and how do you accept it
you know i'm trying to justify and
explain rationalize things to myself
the first time we hear a a solo french
horn sort of echoing the the heroism of
the olympics
kind of sound and then this cue the
second cue we're on right here
we hear this sound of us of a solo
female voice and this was something we
developed early on in our work
uh you know maggie's story sort of comes
and goes throughout the film
and this this young uh young girl's
voice and there's an innocence in that
sound which i really loved and a
personality to it
it also really helps you track her story
after being abused by usag by steve
penny by larry nassar
all i wanted to do is get my child out
of there
and take her home and hug her and love
her there's an ache to this whole
movie in which it's about the loss of
innocence in a way you know these young
girls have this amazing
dream and you know this aspirational
optimism and it's just sort of
becomes crushed i try not to
think too much about it i just try to
you know carry on and hope that they
made the right decision for the right
reasons
we're heading now into the butting up of
the two storylines so this is rachel
denhollander
speaking in an archive clip to mark
alicia one of the indie star reporters
who drove down to
louisville to interview her for the
first time
and uh one really amazing asset we had
was
that archive of material that the indie
star had collected themselves
when they first started to get into the
story of rachel den hollander jamie
dancher
and jessica howard who were the first
three women to come forward and report
nassar to the journalists
and i just i love this incredibly
vulnerable footage
of rachel as set against in dissonance
to the main character interview we do
for the film with rachel where she is
incredibly healthy looking she's
pregnant she's confident
and the the dissonance between her
vulnerability and
how thin she was she describes not being
having been so nervous coming forward
she wasn't able to eat
her road to healing through coming
forward
and through reporting and through the
gathering of all these other women
who had similar experiences um is really
quite
um a beautiful thing so we were very
grateful to have that asset
now we're seeing andrea mumford who is
the
police investigator at michigan state
who gets the call from rachel den
hollander about
her criminal complaint against nassar
i'd asked her what's the doctor's name
and she said larry and ask her
i had heard of him from a 2014
investigation
where another survivor had reported that
he had sexually assaulted her
during medical treatment but the case
was presented to the prosecutor's office
and they declined to to charge it at
that time
athlete a is really the story of the
stars aligning
where the reporters the journalists the
lawyers the criminal investigators the
prosecutors
really all came together at their very
specific moment in time
to bring down this one uh guy within
usag
and here we're about to see the footage
where um the police
investigator andrea mumford meets nassar
for the first time
and he comes in kind of all
sort of cock-sure and confident that
he's going to be able to squirm out of
yet another
complaint against him and you you watch
his body language change and this
incredible surveillance footage that
police took of the first nassar
questioning now
how long have you been doing this
technique i have a video
from 30 pounds ago um
would have been in the 1990s and i
started
asking him about the 2014 investigation
there were certain protocols that were
put in place
about getting informed consent having
another medical person in the room
wearing gloves
have you had any instances where there
hasn't been anyone in the room for an
exam
on occasion of course you know i mean
that just is the way that with medicine
is now it's difficult
would this ever involve like digital
anal penetration
only if we're doing a um coccyx you know
problem
i mean then if i if i actually have to
fix a coccyx when we finally got the
hard drive filled with little nassar
clips
such as this one you can talk about sort
of the decision to
interview nasa not for the film and what
role this
tape plays well certainly his his
character comes through
we felt in the surveillance footage and
i want don to talk a little bit about
the
different ways that we edited this scene
over time but the combination as john
was saying
of his body language kind of changes and
becomes much more nervous and twitchy
over time
because andrea mumford does not let him
lie she just she just keeps going at him
yeah it's it it's such a satisfying
moment in the film because you're
you had to basically like let detective
munford
you wanted to see her like do work her
magic with him
and turn slowly turn the tables of
justice like you're witnessing it happen
if i'm talking to the patient yourself
being a teenage girl
okay all right okay most people that are
sexually assaulted
are very uncomfortable they don't know
what to say okay
he would talk about medical terminology
referencing certain parts of the body
and then you would say oh you don't need
to know all that or you won't
understand all that the sacrotuberous
like
there's it runs from the pubic symphysis
the fossil form process it runs
it's like the pelvic floor okay you
won't understand that
stuff so you're really coming in and i
didn't understand all that
but it didn't matter because he still
couldn't explain to me
how any of those parts or
injuries to them would require
vaginal penetration to fix
do you ever get aroused during these
exams this actually is one
of the only scenes that got longer in
the film because
we let this play long enough where you
see her give nasser enough rope to hang
himself
so it's really amazing like what
bonnie and john was saying just to watch
him come in with his dumb jokes and
you know this is i'm gonna you know i'm
gonna be leaving here soon this will
take five minutes
and then he she just like you know sinks
her claws in him and
and he realizes that he's he's been
caught he goes from like
cocky and relaxed to defensive and
completely exposed
and so like last time there will be an
investigation right
okay okay all right i'm gonna go grab a
park imagining how things could have
been different as steve penny had
asked any questions of nasa you know you
sort of can imagine this totally
different
future it's very powerful too as we
started looking into
the nassar case we talked to nassar's
lawyer
first thing he said was you know this is
a very important man
and you're potentially going to ruin his
reputation here
and so we were very aware of that
ourselves
rachel den hollander was just a
completely credible source
and john manley and jamie dancher
were preparing a lawsuit at that time i
like to think of three-act structures a
lot in a score
and i like the idea of a third act theme
like a piece of music the audience
hasn't heard yet that
launches them into on the end of the
movie because i felt like this was my
third act theme this was sort of the
this cavalcade of women who once they
saw this first story in nassar's denial
of it
who started to come forward so bravely
and there's i wanted to create the sense
of this momentum
sometimes we're asked um did we have the
opportunity to
interview nasser did we think about
trying to get an interview with nassar
and um the truth is we never really
thought about it that way nassar
is a character in the film and um
when you stop to think about it there's
so many little
pieces of of nassar that comes through
and the beauty of it is it's always kind
of coming through
from the point of view of characters
that are that are main characters in the
film
you know see this this man who's had no
spot on his records as far as we knew at
that time prior
begging us not to do that so you know i
had to kind of keep reminding myself i
was like don't feel sorry for him
you know feel sorry for the victims the
survivors and
but but he made it made a good play
[Music]
the former team doctor for usa
gymnastics for 20 years
is facing dozens of accusations of
sexual abuse including one from a former
olympian
a team of reporters from the
indianapolis star published accounts
from gymnasts who accused nassar of
sexually abusing them
during supposed medical procedures
in that interview with nassar's lawyers
he
said that he had never performed an
intravaginal procedure
which was really his downfall
i also love how tim tim evans really
shows his humanity
in the interview piece just after the
audio interview with nassar
it kind of got to him he talks about
that i think that's a very unusual
trait for a journalist especially an
investigative journalist to
admit that they feel those things and um
it just we always we always we we had it
in the film we had it out of the film we
finally just
decided it had to be included because it
was so
symbolic of this particular team of
journalists who
carried such humanity on their shoulders